- [Narrator] In movies, cars
get blown up and flipped.
They define characters or
they're characters themselves.
Sometimes they're the center of the shot
and other times they're in the background
just helping to set the scene.
But where do these cars come from?
Some of them come from the Auto Film Club
in Staten Island, New York.
- We rent vehicles, we modify
vehicles, we acquire vehicles.
- [Narrator] The Lucci family has been in
the car rental business for 43 years.
Max's father Ralph had an
autobody shop with his brother
in Brooklyn and they got to
know people with old cars.
- They started getting calls
from different prop masters
and people in the film industry saying,
"Oh, you guys have a body shop
where you have all these older cars.
"I need cars for a period piece."
- [Narrator] After awhile,
they were acting as
liaisons between film
crews and car owners.
Eventually they started buying cars
to keep in their own inventory as well.
Now, they've got about 190
vehicles available on their lots
and a database full of car
owners willing to rent.
(engine revving)
The cars they have range from flashy,
polished collectibles to beat-up junkers.
- Whether it's your pristine garage queen
from the '60s or '70s or your jalopy,
you know, your Subaru Outback,
whatever it may be
there's always a character
who needs a specific type of car.
- [Narrator] The way it usually works is
a production company calls with
a request for a particular type of car.
If the Auto Film Club
doesn't have the car,
they'll act as the agent
for someone who does
or try to find one to buy.
If they do have the car, they'll bring it
into the garage and make sure it's
running well before it has to be on set.
- If there needs to be a shot where a car
is having a hard brake and it stops
right in front of the
principal actor or actress,
then we'll inspect the
vehicle, check out the brakes.
- [Narrator] This is all part of
getting the car stunt ready.
They might also prepare
a car to burn rubber,
be smashed, or get flipped.
For the movie This Is Where I Leave You,
the Auto Film Club had to find
an old Jaguar and then gut it.
- We removed the motor and
the transmission from it,
made it hollow, and
then we had some people
from special effects come in and fabricate
a fake-looking motor that
we put into the vehicle
and then we had to weld
a pipe so that the actors
who were flipping over this
real car could use it to
gain leverage and actually
flip over this old Jaguar.
- [Narrator] You might not know it,
but you've probably seen some
of Auto Film Club's cars.
They supplied about 14 cabs for this scene
from the 2002 Spider-Man movie.
The rest you see were added
digitally in post-production.
They supplied the cars for Men in Black,
including the Zap-Em van
and the car that Will Smith
smashes through when he
shoots the cricket gun.
That one was the Lucci family's
car when Max was growing up.
- It used to get driven
to school, kindergarten,
every single day, we called it Old Betsy.
- [Narrator] Auto Film Club
has supplied cars for Gotham,
the Americans, Jessica
Jones, and the list goes on.
- You can never say no
to a potential client
because you never know when
they're gonna call you back.
He told me to call this
person who told me to
call that guy, who knows a guy in Wyoming.
I finally called someone and I said,
"Do you have a 1993 to
'97 Prevost bus hatch?"
And he said, "Yeah, I got
one right in my yard."